if you're having a hard time staying
motivated in your business I'm gonna
share with you the three things that I
do to keep myself motivated every day hi
I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently got asked a question for one of
my YouTube subscribers love you guys
Akshay who wrote in to say hi Evan
you've been really motivating by your
awesome videos thanks man
means a lot how do you keep yourself
motivated what motivational books are
you amongst these days this is a
fantastic question and one one that I
think everybody will wrestle with and I
don't believe that there's anybody in
the world who who is everyday always on
always super motivated you know you may
look at me and look at the channel see
what Evan he's always excited and
energized and motivated but I have my
down days too right I mean I've created
a system that really works for me but
know that nobody is perfect and and I
need the system to keep me motivated
everyday as well so I'm gonna share with
you the three things that I do that keep
you motivated so number one is have a
big why and the big why is why are you
doing this right what's your purpose why
did you launch this business why is it
important to you I've talked about this
over and over and over again on the
channel but you can't be in business
just to do it to try to make money right
you have to be doing this for our deeper
more meaningful purpose the money is not
going to keep you motivated right the
the search for money is not gonna keep
you motivated enough that stay with this
business when it gets really hard so you
have to have a deep passion for what
you're doing and have this big why right
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs
that's a big motivating exciting goal
for me I want you to do well right
everybody watching I want your business
to do well I want to play a small part
of that that motivates me I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs and having that
big why keeps me excited so you want to
have a big goal and a big dream and a
big why for your business as well
something that excites you and makes you
want to get up and go to work number two
is have a little why and the little why
are the little things that you do every
day to help remind yourself of the
impact that you're having when I find
sometimes is that big goal can be too
big it can be too
this animus ominous ominous it can be
too big and and then it makes it seem
like that's not possible like I can
never do that right there sometimes we
wake up when you're bold I can totally
do that
and some days you wake up like oh I
can't do that there's no way I can do
that at Who am I to do that and so
that's where the little Y's come in the
little Y's are the little reminders from
people who you help this show that hey
you're having an impact and you're
making a difference so for me to share
an example my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs a billion are you guys
grow your business that's my big why the
little why are the YouTube comments the
Twitter comments the little feedbacks
that I get from you emails saying hey
your video your message helped change my
life that's why I incorporate social
media into my morning routine because it
helps me start my day when I get my
youtube comment feed full of awesome
comments from you guys seeing how much
of an impact I've had on you and your
business that makes me excited right
that makes me want to keep going and
want to do more and gets me motivated to
get up and do something just a little
bit harder today now I'm lucky because I
have an audience now and I've built it
up and had some traction of momentum
success but I was doing this when I was
getting started as well
my first sessions in helping people were
making presentations and doing live
seminars and I would have them fill out
feedback forms at the end to say what
they thought about that they liked had
not liked it what could I improve on and
there were so many positive comments
that came from those sessions that what
I would do is take their comments and
put it into a PowerPoint file and I
would watch the PowerPoint file every
morning because I could have a great
session one night right Thursday night
have a great session and really touch
people's lives and feel like man I'm
doing some great work I'm really having
an impact be on top of the world and
then I go to sleep and I wake up on
Friday mornings and the energy is gone
it's like well what happened and you're
starting from scratch I find for me I'm
starting from scratch every single day
so I need to have this routine built in
to help me stay motivated and be
successful so looking at that PowerPoint
file of all the feedback and comments
that I got from people who came to my
events that really
we stay motivated so you can do it too
by looking at people who you've helped
and maybe an email that came in just
save the best of the best stuff and
surround yourself with that every
morning to know that yes that you have
this big goal that you want to
accomplish but on a small scale you're
helping people to write like the work
you're doing now is important already
it's already having a meaningful impact
on some people's lives and that gets you
motivated to keep going and number three
is environment and routine I'm a huge
believer that you are a product of your
environment you'll probably make as much
money as your parents make you probably
make as much money as your friends make
and you know they'll have the same
impact on the world that they made and
the only way to break free of that is to
change your routine and to change your
environment and so I try to surround
myself with greatness if I want to
achieve greatness if you want to achieve
greatness you have to surround yourself
with greatness that was the whole point
of the morning series that I launched
I've recently launched a morning series
where every morning at 7:00 a.m. it's an
inspirational video from that has a
message from a famous entrepreneur and
I'm adding to it and I felt personally
me like I didn't still you know you may
look at me and say hey Evans got it all
figured out and I'm so grateful and so
happy with what I've accomplished so far
but I want to do more right like I want
to have a bigger impact and I felt like
I want something to help people think
bigger to help me think bigger I want
something I can go to every day to help
stretch me to make me think like I can
accomplish more because I live in a
bubble you live in a bubble and you grow
by expanding that comfort zone and so
there wasn't anything out there that I
loved right there's a motivational stuff
where there's like a guy yelling at you
to say you're gonna go do this you let
her go change the world you know it
works for some people it doesn't work
for me right I get more motivated by
inspirational things by stories I seen
people go out and try to do something
that's beyond themselves that makes me
want to do something beyond myself and
so that's why I started the morning
series and so far it's worked that well
you know love to know you know your
feedback on it but changing your
environment changing your routine
surrounding yourself with greatness in
all aspects the people in your life the
TV shows the YouTube videos you watch
the music you listen
- I have a belief playlist that I
listened to every morning that I
recently made public so you could check
it out if you want to hear what I listen
to but put on songs that make you move
that make you want to dance and make you
want to get up and do something right
everything in your life has to make you
become the best version of yourself if
you want to go out and do something
great in this world so that's all I got
your big why your little why and then
your environment and your routine
believe for those who are watching I'd
love to know how you stay motivated if
you have any tricks or tricks
trick tips or tricks that you want to
share put it in the comments below I
love to see it and follow along and if
you guys like this video and you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to
the newsletter and the channel thank you
so much for watching I'll see you soon
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo - Doo